the number one cause of death
on
all of those journeys out west was
falling off a wagon and being run over
by the wagon that was the number one
cause of death and
really when we were filming the show
that was the most dangerous thing that
was part of the show and
and my heart was always in my in my
throat because my wife was driving the
wagon all the time that was terrifying
i um and i was
i trained on the wagon
driving the wagon i was actually really
good at it
that was another level um
we had a little incident during the
filming of that and it it got real it
got real
i'll never forget taylor
came up to me after the shot and he said
well that was
that was that was western that was real
western
that that actually happened on our 25th
anniversary at four in the morning and
and i'm swimming alongside her on my
horse and
literally he was
in complete fear just doing everything i
could to be ready to save her if i
needed to save her so it i mean there
was a lot of authenticity in that the
road west is filled with failures
it was a dream
and the dream is coming true taylor
actually called tim
and told him who's gonna tell
i'm not gonna talk about myself in third
person but he's gonna tell me that i
needed to
yeah have
gosh how do i say this uh anyway have
stopped shaving or whatever
have armpit hair
and we were actually at a wedding
our nephew's waiting
and he told me he said you have to tell
her now to stop
whatever
shaving whatever and he did right there
during the reception at the sweat at our
nephew's wedding
and i literally almost dropped
my food on the floor um but yeah i had
to do it and um
i'm happy that that's over
i believe in you
not believing that boy
and i believe in our daughter
and that's all
i'm a crier you know i i i can watch a
sappy commercial and start crying there
were so many times in this show like
every episode there was a time where i
could cry or wanted to cry but james
couldn't cry so i had to save it for
just one or two times where james could
cry because he's such a stoic guy so
that was probably the toughest part for
me emotionally was to not cry and try to
hold everything in and sort of be
monotone in the times that that as me as
a person would be like boo and you know
wanting to go hug my wife